if you make a representation to the
meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to possibly use of the sounds
recordings for webcasting
or training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
record films
photograph and broadcast this meeting
when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
that's that done with now i'd like to
introduce the officers who are doing the
meeting today so um first of all
david would you like to introduce
yourself
david david price lighting officer
catherine
uh catherine green licensing officer
emma
um emma's not here chair all right
nigel yeah nigel dulu legal advisor to
the committee
and karen good morning karen sayer
governance officer
i are now moved to the agenda um
apologies for absence
thank you chair we've received apologies
from councillor beer
is that all yes okay
mr chairman um councillor nunn appears
not to be here
yeah but he hasn't oh i am here chair
he is here but he's not on the screen
okay thank you john
thank you uh decorations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
apologies
would you like me to carry out the roll
call vote yes please
um apologies roll call for members
present
members if you could reply with good
morning or present counselor airs
counselor airs turn your mic on soon i
know
when i keep press and it's going off
it keeps going off and on yes i'm here
oh
i'm here councillor carpendale
yes president good morning councillor
creswell
i don't believe he's here
councillor dawson present councillor
gould
yes good morning councillor grandin
present councillor babery
present good morning councillor newman
yeah present and councillor nan present
thank you chair okay thank you
um is there any declarations of um
interest are there any decorations of
interest anybody
use your hand function if you have
no okay right i'd like to confirm
the minutes held of the meeting held on
the 14th
of august 2020 are there any
points regarding the accuracy of the
meeting
anybody no can i have a proposal please
margaret is that a proposer yeah
margaret mayberry thank you
have a second to please
have you got a second there yeah i'll
second it
assertion yeah okay
right the cabinet's officer will now
take a roll call
karen thank you chair members please can
you reply with four against rip stain
councillor airs four
councillor carpendale absent
councillor dawson four
i wasn't part of the committee at that
time
so i think i have time
thank you councillor mabry
we can't hear your counselor maybe
her mic's off
margaret your microphone's off
councillor mayberry up
sorry um i have been trying desperately
to take it
um off on
mute so i apologize for that it just
would not work
so something is sticking um leave it on
margaret
four thank you councillor newman
yeah four councillor none four
okay the minutes have been confirmed and
will be signed at the appropriate time
right um have we got any notifications
of any petitions
karen none received chair okay
we'll now move to paper blr stroke 20
stroke 2
the licensing act of 2003 statement of
license policy
for the five year revision uh catherine
green
we'll go on do this catherine
thank you chair um the purpose of this
report is to report back to the
licensing and regulatory committee
the outcome of a full targeted and
public consultation which ran between
the 20th of august 2020
and the 16th of september 2020 in
respect to the above statutory policy
revision relating to the licensing act
2003 functions
since november 2005 local licensing
authorities have been responsible for
functions under the licensing act 2003.
section 5 of the licensing act 2003
requires that each licensing authority
shall determine and publish a local
statement of licensing policy
relating to the discharge of its
licensing functions under the act
the licensing team revisited the
statement which has been in effect since
january 2016.
this report seeks the approval by the
licensing and regulatory committee of
the revised policy statement
attached as appendix a for
recommendation
onto full council so that it may be
adopted for publication and ready to
take effect from the 7th of january
2021 so the recommendation
is that the post consultation draft in
respect to the licensing act 2003
functions as attached
as at appendix a be approved
and that the recommendation to full
council is that the statement of
licensing policy document be adopted
the reason for this decision is it is a
statutory requirement to review and
re-adopt the council's licensing policy
this is a statutory function the
licensing team has today
undertaken the necessary preparatory and
consultation work within existing
resources
and fee structure and by working
collaboratively wherever viable
in general terms the licensing no sorry
in general terms the legislation aims to
secure full cost recovery
of administrating licensing act 2003
functions
through fees payable for license
applications and ongoing maintenance
the fee banding system and fee levels
are currently set by central government
by regulation
the previous government had decided in
early 2015
to not activate the provisions of the
police reform and social responsibility
act 2011
section 121 of which would devolve free
setting to local licensing authorities
this will be the fifth edition of the
council's statement of licensing policy
under the licensing act 2003. the
licensing team has the necessary
experience stakeholder contacts and
networking in place to ensure that a
wide
and balanced consultation has taken
place the consultation took place over a
period of four weeks through various
channels and media
adoption of the licensing act 2003
statement of licensing policy
is a function reserved for full council
following the consultation exercise baby
district council received one response
from the response received the necessary
changes referenced have been made to the
draft statement of licensing policy
and that concludes my report chair
[Music]
thank you catherine right is there any
um
points of clarification for members
um actually there's sorry there was just
one did you just say there was only one
response
to this yes there was
but we haven't yeah sorry what i was
going to say is we haven't
based i just wonder whether it should
have been
a bit more wide what do we approach
people or
are we actively um seeking
perhaps feedback doesn't seem a lot of
people to base our
policy going forward on one feedback
does it really
catherine can you tell us how many
people it's sent out to it's sent out to
all the parish councils isn't it
uh yeah so appendix d was the list of
consultees that we sent them
out to um we sent it out to 150
um different um people those were
it was sent to the library so it gave
people the opportunity to access
the um policy review from libraries
and it was sent out to all parish
councils um anybody who has an interest
in the licensing act
um policy as well it was sent out to so
that was existing premises license
holders
club license holders um green king for
example was also
um sent it along with punch taverns
where the spoons etc
and the local schools were also informed
of the policy
um so we did quite an extensive
can i just sorry ask catherine is what's
slightly bothering me with this
is that you know we get all these
documents and people tend to read them
and delete them
and i'm just wondering whether we should
have been a bit more proactive
um you know bearing in mind we've set it
out to 150
people and only had one response
i just wonder whether going forward next
well it's gonna be five years isn't it
but it just seems to me
not really um we don't seem to have been
terribly proactive have we
well it's been do you think you've just
been yeah
yeah i i think it's been sent out to a
plenty of people to be honest with you
we've covered most and
if we've had one one person make a point
which we've rectified i think we've done
it right to be honest with you
you know it's it's not it's all emailing
out what my worry is a lot of
lots of people just get these emails
just delete them don't actually i mean
had we had response back come
coming back saying oh we don't need to
make comments because it is okay
that's one thing but to have had no
responses from 150 doesn't seem
um
it means they've read it and they're
happy with it but as you know is a lot
of people don't read it you know they
just that's what's going to say it says
to me people aren't reading it at all
are they really but that that's not our
fault though we
send it out to everybody no i mean it's
just something flagged up
yeah all right thank you for that okay
um
that's the clarification uh right we
moved to debate
is there any debate on this sorry chair
we've got two other
three other councillors with their hands
up i'm sorry
[Music]
and councilman councillor grandin
okay i'll do councillor grandin first
thank you chair um i was just going to
say that this
the main body of the license
act has been in um existence for some
years so i think people
know how it works and so they would only
object if there's something
or offer a change if there's something
that doesn't work for them
so i think um if if we haven't had
responses especially as it's been sent
to
bodies and organizations to whom it
would
um have a great effect if
um it hadn't worked for them they would
then
make comments i think i think we can
comfortably assume
that if we haven't heard from them
they're comfortable
with it as they see it as it was sent to
them
okay thank you catherine uh margaret
mayberry
um thank you mr chairman um i've got a a
couple of questions
if i may um the first
one is um it states um
enforcement will take place if
misdemeanors happen and i hope that's
the right
description for this could someone
explain to me which officers that will
be
because we have an awful lot of um
building regulation um enforcement going
on do we have a separate team for that
that's my first question
if that could be answered first please
catherine would you like to do that yeah
that's fine um enforcement is dealt with
by our environmental health
team and they act as our enforcement
thank you thank you thank you very much
um
the uh a comment that i would like to
make um following councillor dawson's
was i was actually there um in 2015 when
the
original when the previous review took
place we did actually have more
uh replies um i have looked at the list
and it's a very similar list
to what we had in 2015 the one
parish council that did reply i think
should be congratulated
um for actually replying um
the other question for officers is
do you do you think in your opinion
that the lack of reply would be because
of the covet situation
okay catherine would like to come back
to that one
i i don't i don't really know um to be
honest
why there was a lack of response in
regards to the policy
we followed the um the normal process
for
advertising and distribution to all the
relevant parties
it could have had an effect potentially
um on response um
other than that i can't definitively say
i'm afraid
if i could come back mr chairman my
second question is
um because i'm sorry i
if it was in the newspaper i didn't see
it did we actually advertise it in the
local newspapers please
um yes it was advertised in the local
newspaper and it was also advertised on
our customer access
point centers and um our endeavour house
address
thank you on our blog i do have
two other questions i did write and tell
david price that i had several questions
um yesterday um okay mentions
right to work um
and obviously uh whoever
wishes to be employed um within this in
these industries has to give proof uh of
right to work
is there a statutory requirement
and i ask this very sensitively because
of some of the
issues that we cover such as security is
there um
a proof that those who have a right to
work
have enough of the english understanding
um i'm asking this sensitively because
i am concerned that perhaps in the
security industry
if there isn't enough understanding um
there may be a slight different
cultural exchange or there might be the
fact that
someone says something um and it is
misinterpreted if an officer could
answer that please
catherine please yeah that's fine chair
um
in regards to the proof of the right to
work under the licensing act we just
require from them a form of
documentation to prove that they have
that right to work
so usually that's a uk passport or a
visa stating that they're permitted to
work within the uk
right okay um could i just have my
concerns on this minute but sensitively
please yeah certainly um
we um we do hope to attract
um a diverse
population um here in babur and i'm just
concerned that there may not be enough
um understanding
for all so if that could be minuted
please
um and i'm getting to the end of the
list you'll be pleased to understand
um the last is um could someone explain
to me and i've got 2.2 down and i'm
sorry
i didn't check which appendix
where it's stating something about
gambling and whether we actually
license the gambling lounges such as
we are beginning to experience within
baby
thank you karen catherine sorry
that's no no problems yet um gambling's
dealt with under a different um
legislation it's done with under the
gambling act 2005 so any
any licenses would be issued under that
legislation rather than the licensing
act
thank you very much that's what i
thought but just to have it confirmed
thank you all right i think sue
carpenter's been waiting soon
that's all right thank you um two small
points
the appendix c on page 45 there was a
query
from someone in holden submaria just
wondered firstly
if she'd had an answer an individual
answer um
and my other question was um amongst
these consultees what were hairdressers
included
uh catherine yeah um so yes the
um the individual did get an individual
response um
and um i i'm going to go back further to
clarify on the club license with
with the individual and in regards to
hairdressers and
the one that is already licensed within
the sudbury area was an existing
license holder so was notified of it but
not every hairdresser
and we were hoping to catch those with
the um normal advertising procedure if
there was any
that required it okay that's when we all
see our hairdresser's next wielder will
mention it
thank you okay all right dan gold
thanks i don't want to leave with this
point because i'm aware that we've
probably already finished on it but
we cannot extrapolate anything um from
the fact that we only got one response
to the consultation
because we don't know we can only assume
it guess the consultation went to where
it needs to go didn't it
it went widely might it be useful to
save revisiting this this
conversation at future meetings to just
put in a clause if it's possible
catherine or david that says
we will assume a non-response means that
you're happy with it
and then we can begin to extrapolate
extrapolate some data which is
meaningful
thank you chair thank you for that i'm
quite happy with that what do you think
catherine
yeah that sounds absolutely fine too
we're happy to do that
okay margaret if you you've come up
again have you got another question
now just left your mic on no i'm i'm
sorry i keep
trying to move things i think i've got a
sticky keyboard i'm sorry about that
mr chairman okay i think sean's waiting
shant
um yeah i just wanted to um just moving
on slightly
and make a a just if a clarification can
be made about
on page six where if the purpose of the
statement the licensing policy why we've
decided
um to not to inform residents of
businesses about
how the authority will make the decision
um i'm just sort of slightly in contrast
to the fact we're sending this
out to why that was deleted out if we
well i would thought we would be sort of
doing the opposite of this is that
is that a national thing that's been
removed from the government guideline
papers
the reason for its removal is it was
duplicated in that section
so we removed one part of it but it's
still
in in the actual policy
well later on in in the same section it
was just
it was repeated so we we took it out it
hadn't been noted
um in the original second bullet is that
meant to be provide a basis
for is that meant to mean this because
it's not quite the same is it that's
what i'm wondering
there's a difference between it's a 2.1
um we can include it back in if if um
well i just think it it would be
appropriate don't you i'm sort of i'm
not quite sure why it's been removed
and maybe it's because national
guidelines have said that but
i mean you said it's been included and
it doesn't seem to be
to me that it has been
okay we as officers felt the the first
point um covered
the what we were basically telling
uh the residents and businesses but
we're happy to put that back in if
if necessary it should be yes i think it
should be included and the other one
is um on is
uh page 20 is it
uh
i think gotten i'll come back to you let
me find it again i had another one in
here and i've written the wrong number
down
okay all right sue carpenter wants to
speak
um yes just just on councillor dawson's
point there um
does the second bullet point on in 2.1
of the policy
not cover her concerns
no it seems to be
very similar
talking about the parameters within
which
um does it really need the next bullet
points residents and businesses and the
other things well
applicants but i mean it's i mean why
would you remove it unless it's a
governmental guideline
what do you think so do you think we
need to
and it's excluding residential
effectively
isn't it well it says applicants
responsible authorities
residents and businesses yeah but within
the parameters of the licensing
authority
but perhaps just a little clarification
and yeah perhaps
a meeting just clarify that do you think
um any advice perhaps from um
from nigel as to um whether we need to
clarify it or not
as far as i can see the only difference
is it is that the
the deleted bullet point didn't use the
words of the parameters
um other than that i think it does cover
because it says enforce applicants
responsible authorities
residents and businesses of the
parameters within which the licensing
authority will make the decisions
if you think the that use of the word of
the parameter the use of the words of
the parameters is significant
then maybe just tweak that slightly but
i yeah it clearly
does cover residents and businesses in
that bullet point
and it is referring to with you know the
the the licensing decisions and the way
that the local authority will make them
well if you're happy if you think as
long as i just wanted clarity if you're
happy i mean i'm fine with it if you
want to leave it
um okay
and yep sorry the other one mark was on
page 21
um point h which has been deleted and
i'm just wondering
is that it says uh control measures
uh the examples of control measures are
given purely
to assist applicants and it specifically
includes liaison with transport taxi and
private hire
is that because they're the applicants
making it so therefore they don't need
to be included or
um or why is it
again being removed okay
catherine or nigel uh yes sir um
the liaison with public transport um had
been removed from the public nuisance
section
um as it was deemed more appropriate in
relation to public safety this was um
under the home office guidance um
section 102
home office guidance um okay thank you
sean any more that's fine thank you okay
any more questions okay um
no more right we moved to debate but i
think we've done a bit of debate is
there any more
anyone got anything else to say if not
we'll move to a proposal
and uh secondary please do i have a
proposal
yes mr chairman i oppose it
yeah and uh catherine grandin as the
second of thank you very much
mr chairman can i just could i just ask
what date this will take effect from
just
confirm it please i think i think it's
catherine can you tell me what date that
is april next year is it
um no chair this this will um take
effect from
the 7th of january 2021.
okay thank you all right i'm still happy
i'm still proposing johnny again
right there's a any more debate after
we've got a proposal in a second there
or should we move to the
vote everyone happy right um
can the cabinet's officer um read out
the proposal please and take the vote
karen
thank you chair mr chairman just to
interrupt you i shall have to plug my
machine in my battery's running i'm
still here though
okay margaret thank you thank you
so we have um the proposal that the
post-consultation draft
statement of licensing policy in respect
of licensing act
2003 functions as attached an appendix a
to the report be approved
and the recommendation to counsel that
the statement of licensing policy
document
be adopted members please can you reply
with four
against or abstain counselor airs
four councillor carpendale
four dawson
four councillor gold
thank you chair that's carried okay
lovely thank you all very much
right we now move on to um
the hackney carriage table affairs
review
and um david price will present this the
licensing officer
david thank you chair
i don't propose to go into lengthy
detail here
um members will be aware that
um this report came in
february 2020 this year um
where and then on to cabinet
following the cabinet meeting and
feedback this has come back to the
licensing committee
again for consideration before going on
to another public consultation exercise
following input from
cabinet the licensing team
along with the chair and vice chair
uh undertook to have a public
consultation exercise
with the trade in august 2020
and now officers have created a
to following those discussions officers
have created
two further table of fares
both with the 50 and 100 detail within
in appendix a which will be the start
which
is for vehicles licensed to carry no
more than four passengers
um so tariff one starts out at three
pound
20 which is a 20 increase on the current
table of fares
tf2 will be 50 of tariff one
and taf three is 100 of tariff one
appendix b tariff one relates to
turf two and then again takes on the
fifteen hundred percent
from there for the bigger passenger
vehicles of
five to eight seats um
there are two recommendations for
members today and i'll take any
questions from there
yeah okay so have we got any questions
for david
margaret maybe uh thank you mr chairman
um
if uh david could just confirm that
um the taxi drivers are quite uh
content with these proposals now um
unfortunately there was a meeting that i
was supposed to be at but i never got
the invitation so
um with the taxi drivers so um i don't
know what
they were saying at the time um and my
second
and it's a comment really is that we
have seen this before
and in my opinion is much better laid
out
and much easier for us all to understand
but
the assistant manager for food safety
and licensing has
done a sample of drivers
to have a to ask for their opinion
those that you looked at were in favor
of
these proposals this is obviously the
first stage
so this from here we'll go out to public
consultation
may i just come back with that um out of
your um
portion that um were contacted
uh were any of them um unhappy with it
please david
no there were none that were unhappy
with this this proposal
thank you okay i mean we've done a lot
of work that the meeting we had with the
taxi drivers was very very good and we
it's a lesson learned that we should
have done that
earlier stages but we've had a lot of
input from the taxi drivers
they are going to be better off we and i
i think it's going to
be a good thing for everybody um
catherine grandin's got a question
catherine yes thank you claire
um on one of the papers i saw that the
one of the consultation points or notice
points
um was advertised as at
endeavour house and obviously that's
closed at the moment so
is that a matter that should be looked
at or or
is there another place that you're going
to
um advertise instead
the the noticeable endeavor house can be
seen from the front of the building
so when you get up to the front of the
entrance you can see all the notices
at the front of the building but they
will also be at the customer access
points
and on our website
okay thank you is there any more
questions or comments from anyone
so a lot of work's been done on this so
i'm hoping we get it right this time
margaret um just to come back um with
what
david has just said um since endeavour
house is
the address of our business in inverted
commerce for
baby district council then it would have
to be displayed there
in any case okay thank you um catherine
have you
got a question again have you left your
mic
katherine grandin no
okay thank you right is there any more
comments
right have i can can i have a proposal
please
uh yeah so uh sean dawson propose it and
sue carmadill second it
okay um any more debate
right um can we go to the vote on this
thing karen please
thank you chair can i just check that
councillor grandin doesn't have a
anything else to say she's still got a
hand
oh he's gone sorry thank you
so we um can i just check the
recommendation with david please for
this one
because it's a bit more complicated
david would you like to do the
recommendation
certainly chair um
are you proposing option one or option
two chair
just um for for clarification
is that option one option option
but no change you mean option two just
for clarification
hey owners yeah option two
sorry yeah
okay so the recommendation under 3.2
is that the committee resolved to amend
the table affairs as
as per attached appendices a and b
that the instruct officers proceed with
the public consultation notice
advertising the variations in accordance
with section 65 for the local
missed lanes provisions act 1976
and the varied table affair shall become
effective from the 1st
of april 2021
okay thank you and then karen would you
like to take the roll call
thank you chair members please can you
reply with four against rubstain
councillor airs
councillor carpendale four
councillor dawson ball councillor gould
four councillor grandin for
councillor mayberry
i'm in two minds because after and i
will say this why
after david mentioned the date that it's
coming in
um i have a query on it regarding
um end-of-year accounts so i think
i will have to abstain thank you
counselor
thank you for none
counselor none four thank you
thank you chair that's carried okay
that's gone through
all right i think that's the end of
business so i thank you all for
attending
and thank you very much
thank you
you